c'est la conséquence directe des
explosions qui ont frappé ces derniers
jours des bases russes volodymyr
zelensky appelle les ukrainiens à
s'éloigner des cités ennemies mise en
garde concernant les zones occupées au
sud et en crimée là où l'armée
ukrainienne mène actuellement une contre
offensive
ailleurs dans le pays à abuja on enterre
toujours des victimes des combats dans
cette ville aux abords de kiev la
capitale où l'on retrouve pour france24
mélina huet mélina elle décrivait nous
cet événement auquel vous venez
d'assister
à écouter raphaël ça fait partie des
nombreuses enterrement des derniers mois
si on peut encore appeler ça un
enterrement il s'agirait plutôt d'une
mise en terres collectives 21 corps qui
ont été amenés sous nos yeux en début
d'après midi par un immense camion un
espèce de chargement énorme deux corps
qui sont non identifiés pour la plupart
sur les 21 seulement un seul a pu être
identifié des corps qui étaient dans des
morgues alentours depuis plus de cinq
mois depuis l' attaque sur bocsa et
l'occupation par les forces russes de la
fin février jusqu'à la fin mars un
massacre qui aura fait plus de 1300
morts dans la région de kif et plus de
400 à bout de chat même donc des
exactions commises par les forces russes
des viols mais également des crimes de
guerre collectif alors on a eu on a pu
voir on a pu assister à cette à cette
mise en terre avec absolument aucune
famille puisque ces corps n'étaient pas
identifiés mais un prêtre orthodoxe qui
est quand même venu faire une messe en
plein air qui est venu prier pour ces
anonymes il nous a expliqué que ce n'est
pas parce qu'ils ne sont que des numéros
entre guillemets qui ne ce ne sont pas
des êtres humains pour autant et que
c'était important pour lui de prier pour
eux et de les bénir avant qu'ils ne se
retrouvent en terre ils ont
effectivement des numéros sur sur leurs
tombes éphémère pourquoi parce que tous
ont été prélevés leur adn a été prélevé
pour que les familles puissent dans les
prochaines semaines ou les prochains
mois s'ils ont la possibilité et bien
effectuer des tests pour découvrir s'il
s'agit de leurs proches ou non et la
maire adjointe de butch à nous expliquer
que c'était très difficile en ukraine
d'effectuer des tests adn pour pouvoir
identifier les corps en moins de 48
heures qu'on est qu'ils n'avaient pas la
même technologique en france par exemple
et notamment que des gendarmes français
étaient venus les aider il y a quelques
mois et que grâce à ça il avait pu
identifier dix sept corps
vous trouvez c'est justement à la ville
où avait été dénoncé les premiers crimes
de guerre attribués à l'armée russe dans
les jours qui avaient suivi l'invasion
où on est depuis l' enquête où en est on
à écouter et dès le lendemain du départ
des forces russes des jours ce sont
essentiellement des journalistes et des
membres des ong qui ont pénétré dans la
ville avec les forces armées
ukrainiennes et qui ont découvert ces
dizaines de corps jonchant le sol pour
certains les yeux bandés et les mains
attachées dans le dos l'organisation
human rights watch a commencé ses
enquêtes dès le début de cette de la
libération des villes alentour que ce
soit à bout de chahir pin ou un petit
peu plus loin aux pros près de kiev et
donc qui ont commencé a réuni à faire
des photos premièrement réunir des
preuves matérielles et puis et bien les
enquêtes du côté ukrainien se font ils
utilisent nous expliquent qu'ils
utilisent absolument tous les moyens
possibles et imaginables c'est à dire
des photos qui ont été postés sur les
réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux ou
bien des images satellites il ya des
organisations qui travaillent à sa
notamment béline 4 qui fait de l'open
source et une taiseuse de l'intelligence
en source ouverte et qui travaillent sur
des images satellite pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé donc ils
ont identifié un plusieurs personnes qui
auraient commis ces massacres le
problème c'est qu'ils sont probablement
déjà en russie que certains se sont
déployés notamment dans le donbass
certains sont peut-être déjà mort donc
des procès sont envisageables mais
extrêmement compliqué les seuls qui
peuvent être organisés serait par
contumace c'est-à-dire en l'absence des
prévenus donc vous voyez la complication
c'est vraiment pouvoir en au delà
d'identifier les personnes qui seraient
responsables du massacre de les
présenter devant un tribunal en ukraine
merci mais les navettes avec nous en
direct de boue de chasse et à proximité
immédiate de kiev la capitale pour
france 24